BEST OUTSIDE SHOOTERS.
MUSCALA, SHAI, TY JEROME,
WILLIAMS.
YOUR FIVE FOR OKC.
ALEXANDER WALKER.
HE'S GOT TO GET IT IN.
NO TIME-OUTS.
TEMPLE.
TIED AT 110-110 WITH 1.4
SECONDS.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING.
>> OH!
COUNT THE BUCKET FOR THE WIN!
DEVONTE' GRAHAM WALKS IT OFF.
SHEER DISBELIEF FROM PAYCOM
CENTER, AS THEY WILL GO OVER AND
REVIEW THIS IN WHAT IS AN
INCREDIBLE FINISH.
INGRAM THINKS IT'S GOOD.
THE PELICANS THINK IT'S GOOD.
AND NOW WE AWAIT.
>> OH, DEVONTE' GRAHAM BREAKING
THE HEARTS OF THE THUNDER, AS
SGA'S INCREDIBLE SHOT TIED IT AT
110-110.
>> TEMPLE IS TRYING TO FOUL HIM
RIGHT THERE.
WFULLY CLOSE.
SHAI KNOCKS DOWN.
AND BEFORE WE COULD EVEN TALK
ABOUT IT.
HE'S TRYING TO FOUL HIM RIGHT
THERE.
THERE IT IS.
LOOK, I'M TRYING TO FOUL.
AND BEFORE WE CAN EVEN TAKE A
BREATH.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED NEXT,
FOLKS.
>> FROM 70 FEET.
WIN IT BY DEVONTE' GRAHAM, HIS
FIFTH AND FINAL VICTORIOUS THREE
AND THE CELEBRATION ONSET BY THE
PELICANS.
WHAT A FINISH HEREIN DOWNTOWN
OKLAHOMA CITY.
>> AND HE BARELY GOT THAT SHOT
OFFBEFORE THAT LIGHT LIT UP AND
LOOK AT THE EXPRESSION OF SGA.
THAT SAYS IT ALL.
HE MADE A TERRIFIC SHOT TO TIE
THIS BALL GAME MOMENTARILY.